if Batman's Gotham City could be found
in West Africa that city would probably
be Lagos in Nigeria over 13 million
people live here so Batman would have
enough opportunities to chase bad guys
but Gina Martin believes that Nigeria
needs to have its own superhero I think
it was about five years old my mom would
buy me comic books and I would trace
every single one and completely ruin the
comics you know that's basically how I
learned I would put a piece of paper
under make and I'll put my pencil over
Ethan Allen through all over today I
wouldn't print the back of the comic
maybe we go to any school I just
basically traced comics Guardian crime
and other Nigerians superheroes are
brought to life in this comic Republic
studio these five young artists under
GDS supervision want to create an
African Marvel Comics universe but they
also have to ensure that they generate
enough revenue from the few advertisers
they have this is the first of a series
of operated issues this is our test for
enough so that people can see what the
comics and have a feel of what it'll be
like at first before you start releasing
all the issues altogether fantastic it's
really nice its standard everything is
just on point you can see the color
separation it's glossy paper we're proud
of it actually how did people react to
cheetah's comic book creation it seems
that superheroes are long overdue and
urgently needed we discovered as we
spoke to these children in the body
Aslam
21 to grantees I will stop there and I
will give them four for this many people
they are dying why have them to change
breaking if there is a superior in Legos
I will tell him to do so many thing
because Nigeria now we are suffering
freedom where people live in figure we
are living or assuming I am the one I
will do more than they were doing in
Nigeria so that we know I'm a African
here you've got it right says the
founder of comic Republic money comes in
through advertisement and from startup
investments from America cheetah Martin
wants to expand his business further and
he gets some advice from content
director akan Toby Collin Jaya it's a
new spirit traditional mythologies so
yeah it's good it's pretty exciting it's
good stuff right here when we need them
stories about African superhumans
because we first for example and I was
growing up you know I remember that when
I needed to make a decision I would
think about what would superheroes do
when you see somebody that is same skin
tone as you come from the same place
that you're from can be lead to the same
problems that you have this is it for
you to be get back he can do it I can do
it any of the subjects are drawn from
day to day life in Lagos
different locations also help in the
creation of news stories you know we see
our African stomachs we see our
characters as a bridge between Africa
and the world in general we can all be
heroes and you don't have to have
superpowers to do good that's what our
comics say
you